dans cette voiture geneviève ans un
cours de conduite une leçon classique
comme il s'en déroule tous les jours
mais s'il ya bien une question qu'elle
ne s'est pas posée c'est de savoir dans
quelle catégorie d'entreprises est
classé son auto école
je sais pas je n'ai honnêtement je sais
pas eh bien il s'agit d'une tpe une très
petite entreprise c'est-à-dire qu'elles
comptent moins de 10 salariés origines à
la monitrice cette structure est à la
proximité puis l'ambiance l'entente la
communication entre employés entre entre
employeurs et employés aussi du côté du
patron de l'auto école être une tpe
n'est pas une question de choix
cinq salariés mais malheureusement on
aimerait être plus non pourra pas c'est
pas possible au niveau des charges on se
casse fixie un petit peu de tous les
côtés donc malheureusement pourra pas
faire mieux que ça en saône et loire
près de la moitié des entreprises sont
considérés comme des tpe
bon nombre sont dans le commerce de
détail comme ce magasin spécialisé dans
la sonorisation et l'éclairage
ici il ya le patron et un seul employé
dire que les tpe sont de l'avenir dans
le commerce est forcément pas sûr c'est
bien triste parce qu'on voit maintenant
les centres villes qui meurent parce que
les gens se déplacent plus donc je suis
pas persuadé que ce soit l'avenir mais
enfin c'est un statut qui est
intéressant parce que bon on est
indépendants totalement comme dans tout
système il ya donc des bons et des
mauvais côtés
alors quelles en sont les faiblesses et
les forces un ancrage local ce qui
empêche par contre un développement un
peu plus large sur l'europe car les
structures sont trop haut trop fragile
et trop de trop légère pour pouvoir
conquérir les marchés extérieurs
il y a donc une marge de progression
possible en tout cas en bourgogne
franche comté les tpe sont pour le
moment un maillon clé de l'économie